do you remember the when everybody used  to say with the pound is the pound is  two times the US dollar look at this  right here zoom in a little bit zoom in  a little bit zoom in a little bit go to  go to 2008 or 2009 whatever that is what  is that so a little bit more a little  bit more a little bit more 2007 2008. it  was just so you know at the heist it was  2.11 to the dollar and it dropped to  1.035 they're sitting there saying do  you know what this means though like  what you were buying your old money  can't buy what it was buying wow so say  you're sitting on 250 000 to buy a house  that's worth two hundred fifty thousand  dollars but then it drops from two to  one to one that means you now need five  hundred thousand dollars okay to buy the  same thing you were gonna buy import  coming in this is a real issue in  Ukraine in the UK